des traits de couleurs tracé au marqueur
mais charline élèves de troisième ne
dessine pas j'ai fait un circuit pour un
petit robot qui va suivre la ligne noire
et avec des codes de couleurs qui bat ça
représente dans le code
par exemple il y en a des turbos il y en
a pour les moins vite
il y en a où ça gagne en point comme
charline très élèves découvrent de
nouveaux robots une matinée robotique
proposé par canopée 78 et la délégation
académique au numérique éducatif
c'est avant tout un événement qui permet
justement aux professeurs de
de tester ses ergots pour plus tard
travailler avec avec ses robots dans
leur classe travail et la programmation
avec tout type tout type de robot
puisque chaque robot a sa spécificité
au collège paul eluard de guyancourt des
élèves travaillent depuis le mois de
septembre et qu'une option informatique
robotique
l'idée étant d'arriver à les faire
travailler différemment dans un système
où il n'y a pas de notes pas
d'évaluation est vraiment leur apprendre
à travailler ensemble et à essayer de
trouver le en quoi ils peuvent être
complémentaires ce sont des élèves qui
viennent de différents horizons avec des
niveaux qui sont complètement disparates
et on a même un élève qui vient de
classe ulis par exemple et on obtient
aujourd'hui des changements
comportementaux qui sont extrêmement
intéressants on peut on peut décider de
ce qu'on veut faire si on veut faire des
choses et en fait on est encadré donc si
on veut par exemple de lettre de l'aide
si on veut changer de projet on peut et
c'est vraiment bien
ces matinées robotique sont une
nouveauté pour cette année scolaire
cinq autres seront proposés dans le
courant 2010 9